Thank you so much.
I'm so excited to be here.
I am 6'1."
And I've been this height
since I was 12.
[ Light laughter ]
Yes.
First day of high school,
I walked into this --
"Shh, shh, shh, shh, shh.
The teacher's here."
[ Laughter ]
The rude girl in the front
raises his hand, like,
"Miss, ain't you our teacher?"
"Um, no, I'm your classmate.
What do you think this is,
'21 Jump Street?'"
[ Laughter ]
Elementary school was worse,
because I was chunky.
Yeah, and when you're a fat ki
growing up,
you got to go the extra mile
to make friends.
I was doing stuff like
magic and taxes.
[ Laughter ]
I'd be on the playground like,
"Abracadabra, it's an audit.
Let's play."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I did get bullied
every once in a while.
One day I came home from schoo
traumatized.
I'm crying in the mirror like,
"This is it.
I don't have any friends.
I'm going to run away."
And my knees looked up
at me like,
"Baby, we ain't running
nowhere."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
My guardian angel pops up,
"Chloe, you can't run away
Tomorrow is pizza day.
Ye-e-es!"
[ Applause ]
"Thank you, pepperoni.
I'm staying."
Oh, come on, don't act
like pizza day
wasn't the best day
of elementary school.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah!
That cement block of dough
those two little Basquiat
paint brushes of tomato paste,
the cheese -- the cheese,
it never melted.
It just stared at you like
"You're going to get cance
at 50. Um...
[ Laughter ]
This is not real cheese."
I think about my childhood
a lot 'cause I'm not an adult.
Yeah. My parents have been
married for over 40 years.
My mom was 19. My dad was 24
when they got married.
Meanwhile, I'm 38, single,
and I like to take picture
the of ugly babies in public
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, come on,
you can't get mad at me
for having pictures of you
gremlin in my smartphone.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Oh, if you're not laughing
uh, I probably got your relative
in my phone right now.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
I used to be a very mature
adult, don't get me wrong.
Before I was a comedian,
I was a journalist.
I did investigative reportin
for over a decade.
And then I realized,
people don't read.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so I found
another dream.
And now, in the eyes
of my parents, you know,
it's a competition.
My younger brother's 15 year
younger, and he's killing it
So now my parents look at me
like I'm the first pancake
Mm-hmm. Yeah, you ever
go to make pancakes,
it's been a long time.
The batter's extra lumpy.
You're looking like, "Hopefull
it'll work itself out."
[ Laughter ]
You pour it in the pan.
The pan is way too hot.
It burns instantly.
It's not even round,
it's oblong staring up
at you like,
"Mom, Dad, what are we going t
do about this?"
You're like,
"Um, we're going to put yo
at the bottom of the stack
and hopefully in 38 years,
somebody will want this
messed-up pancake."
[ Audience "ahh"s ]
Oh, yeah, okay, fine.
All hope is not lost.
Okay, my brother,
he went to Yale University
Yes.
But he majored in photography.
[ Laughter and applause ]
At Yale University.
Listen, y'all, it's time to warm
this pancake up, okay?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, yeah, my parents
are devastated.
They called me up,
"Chloe, can you please
talk some sense into
your brother?"
"Mom, Dad,
don't worry about it."
I called him up at Yale.
"Hey, Chad, follow your dreams."
[ Laughter ]
I'm not an adult.
Now, listen, just because
you have a life dream
and it doesn't pan out,
doesn't mean you throw
your whole life away.
I thought I had my life
figured out.
When I was in my early 20s
me and my girlfriends
would get together for brunch.
We'd sit around the table,
talk about our future.
"I'm going to get married.
You're going to get married.
I'm going to have a baby.
You're going to have a baby.
I'm going to start
a fashion line.
You're going to start
You're going to
start a fashion line."
None of us knew how to settle.
But now I'm almost 40.
The conversation is
much more realistic.
"I'm going to get a roommate
You're going to get a roommate
You're going to get a roommate."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"I'm going to get a cat.
You're going to get a cat.
[ Laughter ]
"I'm going to go to therapy.
You're going to therapy."
Thank you, guys.
My name is Chloe.
Thank you so much!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Chloe Hilliard!
For more, visit
chloehilliard.com.